well first of all when I I first knew
you and a lot of people knew you as
someone who's just really naturally
funny you were just you know you're very
gifted you're very naturally funny and
that is how I first knew you and you'd
come on the show and I thought I'm
always fascinated to figure out when did
you realize you were funny did you
always know where you went is when you
were a little kid that's usually when
people figure it out they figure out a
very early age that I've got this power
I've got this thing I can do I always
knew knew that I was
funny but it wasn't I didn't know that
comedy was a gift because I got in
trouble for it I got pinched in church
you know for clowning around you know
what I mean like a nun or uh by my mama
oh by your mom yeah okay so you knew
you're you knew you're a salent that's
the important thing you could identify
your a salent yeah yeah so and I would
get talks too much on my report card and
my mother's likewell what are you in
class talking about I I me I I sometimes
I tell jokes she's like I got a joke go
get the belt you know what I mean and
and so I got in trouble for it so I
didn't know it was a gift
until um
1993 um my brother was murdered on a on
his high school campus and my mother
says I'm getting in the bed and I'm
never getting back out so I'm like well
what could I do and I was like 20 2 2 23
and I'm like I don't know what to do but
I do know I can make my mama laugh so I
started performing at the foot of her
bed every day I would come over there
and do my bit and do my jokes and do my
voices and one day I came over and she
wasn't in the bed and I said mama she
said we're in here I'm like who is we
well I went across the street and got
Miss Brown and Miss s and I told him you
was funny get that karaoke microphone
and stand up there and tell these people
some jokes I was like what what is
happening and so in that moment I I
tapped the karaoke mic is is this thing
on how's everybody doing in the living
room I don't know what I'm saying like
what am I doing up here be good to your
waitress she works hard and so I I
started as I'm telling my things and
doing my bit that's when I realized that
comedy was healing yeah I realized it
was a gift and and that voice said to me
cuz I was trying to get jobs as a very
serious actress I'm like listen are they
doing part six of roots I would love to
be the lead slave you know I wanted to
cry and fall all out on camera couldn't
get a job anywhere in town who was your
role model as a kid for the actress that
you wanted to be do you think oh um when
I was younger probably more like Sicily
Tyson you know like that that kind of a
Vibe Diana Ross and mahogany but
Majestic these are Majestic people you
know yeah and so when I'm standing there
saying these jokes in the karaoke
microphone the voice as audible as my
own says ni don't be a selfish heer it's
a lot of people suffering go outside and
spread this joy around and I went
outside and I said my name is n Nash and
I'm funny and they were like yes you are
little girl let us give you a job and
that was you know when I knew it was a
lot more to it but it's interesting that
for me it was a revel
that this thing I can do to cheer up my
mom or make people laugh in a tense
situation there's a job that you could
it's actually a job I didn't know it was
a job I mean I grew up in you know
Boston in the 1970s there's there's no
one I wasn't bumping into people in Show
Business I didn't know that it was a job
yeah for the longest time which was kind
of a cool thing to find out yeah I
thought this is just something you do
with people for fun and I mean even the
way son and I sona's my assistant and we
were just we would always mess with each
other screw around and then people would
would laugh and then we put it on camera
now it's like this mini industry I know
it's
true you didn't know that this would
happen when you signed up to be my
assistant no I didn't I didn't you
thought you'd be getting me like foot
inserts you know for the rest of your
life yeah I did that too but yeah and by
the way I need them again oh okay well I
don't assist you any
Janu new guy yeah we need the new foot
insert my
orthotics but but I mean that that was
just something that was natural and real
and then you realize that's all there is
is just if we can put it on a put a
camera on a microphone yeah but I didn't
know it took me a while to know that
yeah and you just seem to you knew you
get into it well I knew I was a lover
first M and then funny second I mean I
remember I liked a boy when I was in
kindergarten and I knew something told
me doll up look nice huh so I wore my I
begged my grandmother to let me wear my
my Sunday dress which was a purple
velvetine so I and my long socks and my
patent leather shoes and my rabbit
jacket you know back then they used to
you know in the 70s they used to take a
little pieces of rabbit and and make you
a little jacket out of it my rabbit
jacket and I put a piece of candy in my
sock
wait a minute you put a piece of candy
where in my sock so in your sock so I
could offer him a a piece of candy in
your sock cuz I didn't have pockets no I
understand that you but so you'd say
would you like a piece of candy and then
and pull it out of my side and then put
it out your and that way that draws
attention to the leg and the ankle come
on I never thought of that me neither
I'm going to try that and now when I
talk to people and say I got some candy
in my sock
it's got a different vibe going to have
a way different vibe go to my van I got
candy in my don't do it Coco not the van
do it the van doesn't work it's a bun
block come on I got a Marathon bar in my
sock it's not good it's not good no in
kindergarten it works now not so much
yeah uh so many things were looked cool
back then and now we're just
[Laughter]
creepy